mitten durch den Dortmunder Stadtteil
Hörde verläuft seit Jahrzehnten die
Hermannstraße doch damit ist jetzt
Schluss denn die Stadt hat über Nacht
die Schilder ausgetauscht und den
Straßennamen geändert jetzt leben die
Menschen hier plötzlich an der Hörder
phönixseeallee das blöde niemand hat ihn
das gesagt ich habe es rein zufällig
auch nur erfahren dadurch dass ich die
Haustür verlassen habe und gesehen habe
dass auf einmal die Hermannstraße
durchgestrichen worden ist dann finde
ich das natürlich nicht in Ordnung weil
ich vor zwei Wochen noch meine neue
Visitenkarten bestellt hatte auf
Hermannstraße 145 jetzt muss ich die
noch mal also die sind jetzt Müll also
ich finde es völlig unprofessionell ich
weiß auch gar nicht was die sich dabei
gedacht haben vor ein paar Jahren wird
der ehemalige stahlstand dort hörte
städtebaulich enorm aufgewertet der
Phönixsee wird angelegt und eine Menge
teure Häuser drumherum gebaut wegen der
städtebaulichen Veränderungen wurde die
Hermannstraße in zwei Abschnitte geteilt
zur besseren Orientierung wird deshalb
ein Teil umbenannt
das beschließt der Stadtrat am 24 März
aus der Hermannstraße wird die Hörder
phönixseeallee den Anwohnern sagt die
Stadt aber nicht Bescheid die
Gewerbetreibenden fallen aus allen
Wolken denn mit ein bisschen
Visitenkarten ändern ist es nicht getan
wir müssen sämtliche Mandanten
informieren auch solche die keine
E-Mail-Adresse haben wir müssen die
Behörden informieren Finanzämter
Berufsgenossenschaften Krankenkassen
allen mit dem wir zusammenarbeiten wir
müssen unser Partnerschaftsregister
ändern alle kfz-scheine müssen
berichtigt werden wenn ich unseren Job
so machen würde wie die Stadt in
erledigt hat hätte ich wahrscheinlich
kaum noch Mandanten die uns vertrauen
würden im Dortmunder Rathaus
entschuldigt man sich für das
informationsdesaster schriftlich heißt
es in Zukunft wird das Tiefbauamt auf
eine Informationsweitergabe an die
betroffenen Anwohner achten entweder mit
einem allgemeinen Flyer der per
hauseinwurf verteilt wird oder in Form
von persönlichen Anschreiben bei den
betroffenen Anwohnern ist man sich einig
auf die Idee hätte noch früher kommen
können das hätte man auf jeden Fall
definitiv besser kommunizieren können
und es ist nervig ja es ist einfach ein
Unding natürlich bin ich bisschen sauer
weil ich bin schon vor frohes Jahr
Oktober geöffnet mein Laden und
wenigstens kurz Bescheid sagen müssen
aber hat er nicht Bescheid gesagt oder
kurz informieren beide Straßenschilder
werden jetzt noch ein Jahr so hängen
bleiben quasi als Schadensbegrenzung
damit sich alle an die Umbenennung
gewöhnen können und nicht noch mehr
Chaos entsteht